je comprends pas comment on a pu appeler
des fruits de mer des fruits de mer s'il
ya bien un truc qui ressemble pas un
fruit c'est ça et quand même un mec qui
s'est dit on dirait un peu une poire
c'est vrai dans les proportions la
couleur non je crois que j'ai un petit
problème avec la avec la nourriture
je ne sais pas m'alimenter bentégeat
j'ai toujours le dilemme entre eux
est-ce que je commande ou est ce que je
me fais à manger un dilemme plutôt vite
réglé en général
[Musique]
ok pizza c'est la vaisselle qui est là
depuis 2008
mais j'ai toujours l'espoir au fond de
moi que un jour oh mon dieu elle s'est
lavé tout seul ceci est totalement
impossible à la vaisselle ne se lave pas
tout seul mais on peut toujours rêver
c'est trop génial pour fêter ça et ça
j'ai aussi du mal à jeter la nourriture
je sais pas pourquoi je garde des vieux
plat complètement pourri dans mon frigo
ils ont commencé à muter et tous ces
super flippant a quand même
mais le pire dans les plus petits se
périment c'est le lait est ce que vous
avez déjà vu est ce que vous avez déjà
goûté du lait périmé c'est juste le truc
le plus dégueulasse sur la planète terre
à san jose même plus goûté le lait pour
savoir s'il est bon ou pas alors j'ai
trouvé une petite technique a salué
chérie tu veux du lait
tiens ok il est pas bon alors si je ne
fais que commander à bouffer c'est aussi
parce que ben je ne suis pas douée en
cuisine tout simplement
c'est même pire que ben haddou et je
suis quand même le seul homme qui peut
louper des pattes de l'eau c'est vrai
merde de l'eau encore plus fort je suis
même capable de louper des plats au
micro ondes et luna fourchette
ah oui je les laissais dans le n'hésitez
pas à partager ma vidéo sur facebook et
à rejoindre ma page
[Musique]
et allez sur cyprien point fr pour
regarder toutes mes autres vidéos et je
vous en prie une pizza
[Musique]
je crois que je déteste cette personne
qui fait des travaux et je crois que
j'en suis sûr